[Music]
you can't name me a disease is not
caused by a nutritional deficiency okay
that's that's very scary elzar disease
other dimensions
Korsakoff syndrome master dementia
hyperactivity disorder oh my goodness
back when I was a kid there was no such
thing as hyperactivity or a TD see TV
shows the kids a TD and they're
interviewing the kid and he has like
Jolly Rancher bag and a coca-cola you're
giving him a stimulant on the kids
sitting with giant black circles around
his eyes and they're gonna put him on
antipsychotics hmm well I'd say I take
those kids that in two weeks time
they're perfectly normal you just get
them off the sugar get them off the
gluten you know make him eat for eggs a
day you get them on the put in Blue Bell
ice cream right put the eggs in there
put bags on top of it and then you get
them on the Alex pack appropriate for
their body weight and it all goes away
well they got to stay away from sugar
and they got to stay away from gluten no
we brought around oats and give them the
90 essential nutrients all that autism
all the ATD ADHD hyperactivity goes away
and that's a profound statement but if
you look in that book rares been cures
which I believe you have in your store
yes raros ventures have pictures how I
am you don't need to go to a child
psychiatrist to diagnose it just get a
coloring book and give them just a whole
slew of colors and somebody was a DD or
ADHD or autism to pick out the darkest
colors will pick up black purple dark
green and then won't stay on the lines
he just scribbled all over the page
whereas somebody else another kid who
doesn't have these problems he'll be
impeccable about choosing the perfect
color for whatever the subject is and
they'll stay within the line they're
very mysterious about staying in the
lines I was actually up in Canada a
couple of weeks ago going to a private
school to lecture to a bunch of teachers
up there and they had this hallway with
all these kids colorings you're like
second grade kids their colorings like
you see in some of these breakfast
houses during Thanksgiving and Easter
and Christmas and Halloween they have
all these color pictures as well that
one's got autism that was this one's got
autism help whispering you got 107 how
did you know those kids had autism well
look he just took black and red and dark
purple and just not even standing the
lines is that's typical of those kids
everybody else stayed in line shows
right color
the earthbender shows you how to
diagnose those things yourself how to
deal with it how to get rid of it and
don't don't get these kids on ritalin do
not do that well they admit ritalin
actually shrinks the brain and expands
the heart why is that well interferes
with nutrients anytime you have the
heart enlarged you're looking at
deficiencies of thiamine congestive
heart failure
are cutting up the heart disease a
deficiency of selenium so many of these
drugs actually interfere with the the
metabolism of nutrients again and so
that's how you get these diseases as
secondary to drugs for instance you take
cortisone prednisone you're gonna get
type 2 diabetes and arthritis it's just
given okay well that's a good well let's
talk about a TD ADHD autism now back
when I was a kid there's no such thing
as those things right in the year 2080
in 1980 there's one out of 150,000 kids
had autism in the year 2000 is one out
of 150 today it's one out of 88 is the
new it just came out last week Wow 1 out
of 88 now has autism Wow and basically
when I was a kid all for my grandparents
were from Eastern Europe they were beet
farmers and beef farmers and so for
breakfast I would have cheese and beets
and beef and eggs and Nigeria no no one
but know that when I was a little baby
nope and we didn't have those types of
diseases well here comes now 20 years
later kids are being fed on these box
cereals full of carbohydrates or sugar
on it they're getting apple juice right
how can you build a brain which is 2/3
by weight 75 percent by weight is
cholesterol and good fats okay and so
now I'll be getting is carbohydrates and
sugar and they're going crazy right not
only did deficient but it's costing them
nutrients to process all that stuff
exactly so it means the nutritional
deficiencies weren't worse right right
and so simply I take kids that haven't
spoken in 11 years you start feeding
amazed you get them on the 90 essential
nutrients which is what we feed animals
and
centrists sixty mineral sixteen vitamins
twelve essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids and after eleven
years enough speaking i have kids who
can read the bible out loud in churches